si on commençait par votre nom 47 c'est
pas un an
non messieurs le mien
vous êtes quoi exactement 1 à ça
et vous êtes là pour tuer qui
vous devriez vraiment me laisser partir
aux dernières nouvelles vous êtes quoi
c'est ici avec moi et c'est moi qui ai
le flag
non monsieur centers vous êtes coincé
avec moi et vous venez apporter le mien
écoutez je sais que ça va vous paraître
bizarre et ça l'est c'est un être humain
génétiquement modifiés plus fort
plus rapide
plus intelligent que le commun des
mortels
on les appelle les agents
qu'est ce que je viens faire là dedans
moi c'est votre père qui a commencé le
programme des agents il connaît leurs
points faibles
vous êtes la clé pour retrouver votre
père
tu as